- Some people may think,
how can it be that somebody
can both gay and a cowboy,
because the cowboy is the model
of the macho, masculine man.
But it doesn't matter whether
you're a man or a woman,
whether you're a butch or nelly,
everybody can find a
place within our community
and within our rodeo circuit.
That's who we are.
(crowd cheering)
My name is Bruce Gros,
and I'm the president of the
International Gay Rodeo Association.
We're celebrating our 30th anniversary
of our finals rodeo today.
Cowboys and cowgirls compete in 13 events,
so that the best of the
best are represented
in our sport at this event today.
- My name is Greg Begay,
and I'm an All Around Cowboy, and I'm gay.
I grew up on the Navajo reservation.
Being on the reservation,
you kinda find things to do,
and rodeo was one of them.
Gay rodeo is more than just a celebration.
I think it's a place for
people to be comfortable.
I don't have to worry
about hiding anything.
(announcer speaking)
(crowd cheering)
- Years ago, professional
cowboys looked upon us
as mocking their sport.
As they've come to know us more,
they've come to appreciate
and understand the fact
that we embrace the same sport they do.
We may express it a
little bit differently,
but we still have the same passion
and dedication to being good competitors,
good cowboys and good
cowgirls that they do.
- Gay rodeo offers a few different events
that traditional rodeo doesn't.
We offer wild drag
race, and goat dressing.
- [Bruce] In our rodeo,
men and women can compete
in every event equally.
You're gonna see men in drag.
I don't know that when people
really come to know us,
they're gonna find a
more warm, supportive,
friendly experience than
they'll find here with us.
- [Greg] Gay rodeo is
a safe space for people
to be accepted with each other.
I've established a rodeo family here.
I can always count on people,
and they can count on me.
(inspiring music)